um you recently had a melanoma scare I
didn't know this somebody said this so
how are you okay now well hence the tape
on I I thought maybe I thought but how
what happened so I am just predisposed
to skin cancer I assume I had melanoma
removed from my back when I was 19. oh
wow and um the reason why I'm wanting to
talk about this well one it's on my face
and I S for and it's been
I had an operation I want to say I don't
know eight weeks or something like that
and um people just there were all these
stories and all these things and I just
was like you know what it's bring
awareness it's for a good cause at the
end of the day I really just want to
highlight people making sure that they
do their regular checks I go every three
months because I am at higher risk for
skin cancer but as you just saw on the
screen it was the smallest little bump
and for months I thought it was just
like a cystic pimple I got it shot with
cortisone no one thought anything of it
but it wouldn't go down yeah and so I
got it checked and someone was like
let's just biopsy we shaved it it came
back and they were saying there's no way
you at your age I'm 38 I guess melanoma
is like really more for either really
young kids or older I'm not a doctor so
I'm not going to talk too much about
this in case I'm screwing anything up
yeah but um we had to do a second biopsy
and it came back that it was a tumor and
they had to operate and so I was like a
tumor in my head tumors are like these
big things that are hanging like a you
know what they you see in the movies so
it was never once
I never thought it was a tumor yeah and
so I'm really grateful that I was
proactive and I
we did the surgery we got it removed and
now I'm just healing and all I have a
scar and okay that will figure out but
like I think a lot of us are making
dermatologist appointments right now
like that's what I'm doing but that's
what I'm so grateful for because I have
had a couple people that because of me
they've gone to their dermatologist they
have had things biopsies I've had
friends that have had things
pre-cancerous that are now removed you
know knowledge is power and if you know
something you can do something about it
and oh I want to know right off the bat
yes I'm that way too yeah I'm always
like getting checked up with everything
like that
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]